[موسيقى]
يجب القول في هذا الخصوص ان ظاهره داعش
تكفيريه ليس لها وجود مادي ومرئي وملموس
في بلادنا بعد مجيء الامارات الاسلاميه تم
القضاء على ثمانيه وتسعين في المئه من
عناصر التنظيم وتم تدميره ولكن من المؤسف
ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه من خلال الاعلام او
تموله الاستغلاله ولكن في الممارسه
العمليه ما نراه في الواقع الميداني
لبلدنا هذه الظاهره لا تشكل تحديا كبيرا
وليست مصدره قلق جاد للامن الداخلي في
بلادنا ولا يمكنه ان يشكل تهديدا من
افغانستان الى دول اخرى
بدايه اود ان اذكركم بان هذه الظاهره
التكشيريه المسماه داعش ليس لها دعم شعبي
في بلدنا وليس لها مكان في بلدنا وكل
ابنائي افغانستان لا يتفقون مع هذه الفكره
وهذه الادبيه والمساله الاخرى فان الاماره
جاده وحاسمه للغايه في شان الحركات
والعناصر التي تضرب امن شعبنا اولها اهداف
تدميريه اخرى لذلك يذكر مره اخرى ان
الاماره الاسلاميه تسيطر على اراضي
افغانستان بالكامل فمن المؤكد انه لا يوجد
ما يشكل تحديا او مصدر قلقا يعرض امن
بلدنا للمشاكل